So, we can informally talk about the correctness
of the distributed mutual exclusion lock algorithm. The correctness
is based partially on some assumptions and partially on
the construction. The construction is that the Q's totally
ordered by Lamport's logical clocks and the PID to
break the ties. But that's part of the construction
of the algorithm. But it also is based on
some assumptions that we make and the assumption is,
messages between any two processes arrive in order.
So messages don't crisscross each other but if I
send a message and I send another message,
the first message is going to reach the destination first,
second message is going to reach the destination second.
And that's what is meant by saying that messages
arrive in order at every node in the
distributed system. And the second assumption is that there
is no loss of messages. So every message that is sent
is definitely received, in order. So these are two fundamental assumptions
that are responsible for this algorithm being correct. Now that you
have seen Lamport's mutual exclusion lock algorithm, time for another quiz.